We've got two right
triangles here.
And let's say we also
know that they both have
an angle whose measure
is equal to theta.
So angle A is congruent
to angle D. What
do we now know about
these two triangles?
Well for any triangle, if
you know two of the angles,
you're going to know
the third angle,
because the sum of the
angles of a triangle
add up to 180 degrees.
So if you have two
angles in common,
that means you're going to
have three angles in common.
And if you have three
angles in common,
you are dealing with
similar triangles.
Let me make that a
little bit clearer.
So if this angle is
theta, this is 90.
They all have to add
up to 180 degrees.
That means that this
angle plus this angle
up here have to add up to 90.
We've already used up
90 right over here,
so angle A and angle B
need to be complements.
So this angle right over here
needs to be 90 minus theta.
Well we could use the
same logic over here.
We already use of 90
degrees over here.
So we have a
remaining 90 degrees
between theta and that angle.
So this angle is going to
be 90 degrees minus theta.
You have three corresponding
angles being congruent.
You are dealing with
similar triangles.
Now why is that interesting?
Well we know from
geometry that the ratio
of corresponding sides
of similar triangles
are always going to be the same.
So let's explore the
corresponding sides here.
Well, the side that
jumps out-- when
you're dealing with the
right triangles-- the most
is always the hypotenuse.
So this right over
here is the hypotenuse.
This hypotenuse is
going to correspond
to this hypotenuse
right over here.
And then we could
write that down.
This is the hypotenuse
of this triangle.
of that triangle.
Now this side right
over here, side BC,
what side does
that correspond to?
Well if you look
at this triangle,
you can view it as the side that
is opposite this angle theta.
So it's opposite.
If you go across the
triangle, you get there.
So let's go opposite angle D.
If you go opposite
angle A, you get to BC.
Opposite angle D, you get to EF.
So it corresponds to this
side right over here.
And then finally, side AC
is the one remaining one.
We could view it
as, well, there's
two sides that make up
this angle A. One of them
is the hypotenuse.
We could call this, maybe,
the adjacent side to it.
And so D corresponds
to A, and so this
would be the side
that corresponds.
Now the whole reason I
did that is to leverage
that, corresponding
sides, the ratio
between corresponding
sides of similar triangles,
is always going to be the same.
So for example, the ratio
between BC and the hypotenuse,
BA-- so let me write
that down-- BC/BA
is going to be equal to EF/ED,
the length of segment EF
over the length of segment ED.
Or we could also
write that the length
of segment AC over
the hypotenuse,
over this triangle's
hypotenuse, over AB,
is equal to DF/DE-- once
again, this green side
over the orange side.
These are similar triangles.
They're corresponding
to each other.
So this is equal to DF/DE.
And we could keep going, but
I'll just do another one.
Or we could say that the
ratio of this side right
over here-- this blue
side to the green side
of this triangle--
the length of BC/CA
is going to be the same as
the ratio between these two
corresponding sides, the
blue over the green, EF/DF.
And we got all of
this from the fact
that these are
similar triangles.
So this is true for
any right triangle
that has an angle theta.
Then those two triangles
are going to be similar,
and all of these ratios
are going to be the same.
Well, maybe we can give
names to these ratios
relative to the angle theta.
So from angle theta's
point of view--
I'll write theta
right over here,
or we can just
remember that-- what
is the ratio of these two sides?
Well from theta's point
of view, that blue side
is the opposite side.
It's opposite-- so the opposite
side of the right triangle.
And then the orange side we've
already labeled the hypotenuse.
So from theta's
point of view, this
is the opposite side
over the hypotenuse.
And I keep stating from
theta's point of view
because that wouldn't be the
case for this other angle,
for angle B. From angle
B's point of view,
this is the adjacent
side over the hypotenuse.
And we'll think about that
relationship later on.
But let's just all think
of it from theta's point
of view right over here.
So from theta's point
of view, what is this?
Well theta's right over here.
Clearly AB and DE are still
the hypotenuses-- hypoteni.
I don't know how to say
that in plural again.
And what is AC, and what are DF?
Well, these are adjacent to it.
They're one of
the two sides that
make up this angle that
is not the hypotenuse.
So this we can view as
the ratio, in either
of these triangles,
between the adjacent side--
so this is relative.
Once again, this is
opposite angle B,
but we're only
thinking about angle
A right here, or the
angle that measures theta,
or angle D right over
here-- relative to angle A,
AC is adjacent.
Relative to angle
D, DF is adjacent.
So this ratio right over
here is the adjacent
over the hypotenuse.
And it's going to be the same
for any right triangle that
has an angle theta in it.
And then finally,
this over here, this
is going to be
the opposite side.
Once again, this was the
opposite side over here.
This ratio for
either right triangle
is going to be the opposite
side over the adjacent side.
And I really want to
stress the importance--
and we're going to do many,
many more examples of this
to make this very concrete--
but for any right triangle
that has an angle theta, the
ratio between its opposite side
and its hypotenuse is
going to be the same.
That comes out of
similar triangles.
We've just explored that.
The ratio between
the adjacent side
to that angle that is
theta and the hypotenuse
is going to be the same,
for any of these triangles,
as long as it has that
angle theta in it.
And the ratio,
relative to the angle
theta, between the opposite
side and the adjacent side,
between the blue side
and the green side,
is always going to be the same.
These are similar triangles.
So given that,
mathematicians decided
to give these things names.
Relative to the angle
theta, this ratio
is always going to be
the same, so the opposite
over hypotenuse, they call this
the sine of the angle theta.
Let me do this in a new
color-- by definition--
and we're going to extend this
definition in the future--
this is sine of theta.
This right over
here, by definition,
is the cosine of theta.
And this right over
here, by definition,
is the tangent of theta.
And a mnemonic that will help
you remember this-- and these
really are just definitions.
People realized, wow, by similar
triangles, for any angle theta,
this ratio is always
going to be the same.
Because of similar triangles,
for any angle theta,
this ratio is always
going to be the same.
This ratio is always
going to the same.
So let's make these definitions.
And to help us
remember it, there's
the mnemonic soh-cah-toa.
So I'll write it like this.
soh is sine is opposite
over hypotenuse.
cah-- cosine is adjacent
And then finally,
tangent is opposite
over adjacent-- soh-cah-toa.
And in future videos,
we'll actually
apply these definitions for
these trigonometric functions.